i know this doesn't fit the theme in the
interview but there's a question i want
to ask you yes okay you're talking about
algorithms i saw a story on tick tock
and i think it was about you doing comic
view and how you hustled your way on a
comic view i thought it was the coolest
[ __ ] story can you tell that here for
this algorithm so comic view is on the
road that was my favorite show
like
i don't even know how old you are 38 i
grew up on tv you watched comic con
remember showtime at the apollo
yeah yeah yeah i remember when cable
kind of sucked and there wasn't that
much [ __ ] on tv i bought the deaf comedy
jam cassettes they would send them to my
house every month i was in
so
explain that to these kids before i was
filipino yeah yeah yeah yeah so
explaining to these kids now it's like
like
i don't know how to explain it but like
a black black comic didn't get
uh
the best rooms or the best nights right
you know i mean so when you had a
successful show like comic view
they weren't gonna put and i lived in
vegas they weren't gonna put them in
caesars
they weren't gonna put them in
the mirage
because they were black comics we're not
ready for that yet right we rarely saw
black comics anywhere okay
and uh so they put them in a restaurant
and this is comic view this is one of
the biggest comedy shows on tv i mean
martin lawrence cedric the entertainer
i remember finding out about the comic
book everybody was called ricky smiley
like this thing was this thing pushed
out
stars yeah but for some reason in vegas
they had to play a restaurant called
country star
which was like a planet hollywood for
country singers wow and and when i found
that out i was i was working on a
dolphin habitat and i was already like i
was already like this is like 1997 or
whatever 96. how long have you been
doing stand up uh i was like seven years
in or so and i was already like booking
like these theaters like i would rent
theaters and and sell tickets and [ __ ] i
would cut make my own i love this and
[ __ ] hustle i'd cut tickets up and
sell them and then uh and then this this
girl that i was working with she was
like you know comic views here i was
like what where it's like country so i'm
like what the [ __ ] is it doing a country
star and uh and i went to uh
uh to my manager and told her i go can i
please just leave early i want to go to
comic view and she let me go home early
and i was a tour guide so i was already
covered in sweat
and i all i wanted to do was go home and
put this suit on that i bought right
because i remember eddie murphy said
always wear a suit because he always
wore a suit and i was like oh okay if
you're gonna do a big show wear a suit
so i i rushed home got my suit i had a
uh and i was still sweaty it was awful
and i grabbed this fake resume this
resume that i made that i opened for all
these people and i and i had a and i
played all these clubs around uh across
the country everything was a lie right
and then uh
all i did were the local comedy clubs
that i the local shows that i did and
then i i brought this
to the front door there was a long line
wrapped around the country star and i
walked up to the security guard
and i go hey man i'm a local comic and i
just want to see if i can talk to the
promoter and maybe just open the show up
and uh and never has a security guard
helped anybody right and the security
guard goes i'll be right back and he
went and got the promoter and i still
remember her name her name is yvette
anderson and she came up to the door and
then uh i go hi i'm a local comic
everybody knows me nobody knows me and i
go i'd love to open the show she goes oh
we already got our comics show's about
to start next i'll take your resume next
time i come back i'll consider you she
goes you want to watch the show i go
[ __ ] yeah that's sweet that she likes to
watch and she let me in yeah and she sat
me down uh next to all her equipment and
she had this thing called a canon three
ccd camera it was like beige and maroon
it was like a huge camera back then i
always wanted one right it was like it
was like a broadcast camera that that
they were selling
it was like eight thousand bucks or
something i saw it i remember oh [ __ ]
that's the camera i want and i was
sitting next to it and it was and
everybody was late right black yeah i'm
not gonna say
i well you're filipino this has nothing
to do with you yeah um
so yeah yeah so uh everybody's late and
the crowd's blowing like because they're
like 45 minutes late the show was like
at eight it's like 8 45 almost tonight
and they're all blowing like start the
[ __ ] show she walks up to me she's
like do you want to do some time no
she goes do you want to do some times
because they're a little late right now
and i go if you can record it with that
camera right there i'll go up and she
goes let me set it up and she set it up
and then uh
and then she brought me on
now you're going up to booze are they
happy that someone's gone i remember the
dj there was no host either yeah and
then the dj goes ladies and gentlemen
joe coyne
and i walked out on stage
i walked out on stage all black all
black people it was just a black room
right and uh and you're not at all what
they're expecting not only are you yeah
they were there to see bo p and uh i
forgot who else was on that show but bo
p was the big one on there he was like
the host
and uh
and he was one of my favorites by the
way i loved bo p yeah and then uh and i
went up and i smashed it yeah i remember
the this is back in the day when they
used to raise the roof
and they were all raised the roof and
then i started doing it and i got all on
videotape
and uh and then i walked off stage
and both he was standing and he's like
who the [ __ ] is this
and she goes i have some local comics
he's like yeah but you ever watched
comic view and i go i love calling you
and i love you bo and he goes you won't
call me people
i go what he goes next week i'm going to
make them call you next week you're
coming out to come with you and i went
on and did confuse the following week
holy these are safe
there's uh you know i got debt jam no no
so definitely
real quick on this story yeah two things
one is um
i have that on tape stuff one i want to
see that yeah uh two do you remember
what you opened with
that's the [ __ ] yeah i'm always
curious
in like harsh scenarios what their first
thing and to be honest i bet you if we
watch the tape we're gonna be like this
is [ __ ] awful yeah
you know what i mean but it was like
i was like seven years in you know what
i'm saying and then it's the 90s comedy
so much
no i don't remember what i i don't even
remember the set yeah you know it's also
interesting
people don't think about
nobody knew filipino comics in 96 so
just the idea of you going out there
doing comedy i'm sure the whole audience
is like what the [ __ ] is this guy doing
here yeah it's crazy so to smash in that
environment is crazy and the opening
must have been a haymaker yeah and it
was it was so cool and then oh man on
their mind this is calling for you this
is this one so then the show starts
right and then the mc goes it wasn't bo
p i forgot bo p was the headliner there
was an mc it was a young comic i forgot
his name
and he went up after me and i remember
he was like
he he didn't know i went up
so i'm just sitting in the audience and
uh and then uh he starts doing his set
and no one's like he's like goddamn you
[ __ ] laughing what do i gotta
do to make you laugh and this black
chick goes put that asian [ __ ]
that was cool man
and then that's how i got uh the black
college comedy tour because i did bet's
comic view and then i did the black
college comedy tour and that's how i met
gary owen and honest john and yeah and i
i was opening for like b flat and some
more i loved it and uh melanie camacho
michael blackson yeah i was opening for
uh jb smooth and i i was bringing them
to vegas
in like 96 like 98 99 i was bringing
them to vegas yeah and uh and i had the
uh
i and honest john goes he goes i'm gonna
get you on def jam man i don't
understand why they haven't said
anything i want to introduce you to bob
sumner yeah i go all right cool and i
was working at like i forgot at some
hotel and he goes all right we're coming
and by the way this was def jam on the
road right and it was at another country
place
called sam's town on boulder highway
they wouldn't put it on the strip yeah
that's what they were doing to like
black comics it was crazy
so uh
so i go to sam's town on boulder highway
and uh and i'm sitting at my sister's
with me rowena and then her fiance and i
remember i got this camera and i go
please whatever you record this set i
need this set
and uh and so now i'm backstage and uh
bob sumner walks up to me with rudy rush
you know rudy wrote yeah rudy's funny
dude yeah he used to host the showtime
with the apollo yeah he's out of dallas
yeah but he he was the host of uh
showtime at the apollo team yeah he took
over for steve harvey funny and now he's
hosting def jam this night
my bad he didn't come backstage yet it
was just bob sumner and honest john and
uh bob walks up to me he's like honest
john he's eating i remember he was
eating he's like honest john speaks
highly of you i'm like yeah he goes all
right this is what we're going to do
we're going to let you go up the house
lights on because they're still sitting
the room
and we're not going to open the curtain
we're just going to open up a little bit
and you walk through the curtain close
the curtain behind you don't say welcome
to def jam just do your set and then
just say good night in your name and
then walk back through don't say
anything about def jam he didn't want me
to be affiliated with def jam just in
case i bombed right
and then he walks off and then and i'm
looking at my sister like i'm gonna
[ __ ] eat [ __ ] why am i gonna go out
there yeah like this is awesome like
he's playing you a little bit yeah it's
like 2 000 people it's like light's
still on they're still seating they're
still [ __ ] it was awful and then and
then the i remember the stage manager
walked up and goes hey man we're at like
70 percent capacity i'm gonna bring the
house lights down a little bit for you
he goes but i can't open those curtains
up he goes i can't do that but i'll
bring the house house light is bigger
yeah right
so literally this is what happens
there's two guys holding the curtain and
i'm standing there like this my sister's
like come on kill it
and they open the curtain i crawl
through
and i'm like hi everyone
and it's just everyone's like and i and
i just go into my act
and
like standing o
right wow and then they start stomping
you can hear them stomping in the
bleachers and then i crawl right back
through the curtain and it's and it's uh
it's bob sumner honest john and rudy
rush who's the host yeah and rudy rush
goes
man who the [ __ ] is this guy he goes
that's honest john's friend he goes what
the [ __ ] did you put him on now
he goes what the [ __ ] man you should
have put him on the show i gotta go up
after this [ __ ] oh it sucks and then and
then uh he was like i didn't know this
[ __ ] was funny they're saying
this in front of me as if i'm not there
yeah yeah yeah
and uh my sister's crying oh my god okay
and then uh and then and i swear to god
just like bo p
rudy looked at me he goes we're doing a
comedy showcase on show time at the
apollo you want to do it
i go yeah i want to do it here he goes
he goes i have my people call you
and he goes and you're going gonna be on
show time with apollo and then literally
like a month later i was on show time
with apollo get the [ __ ] out of here and
then i won't show time at the apollo
yeah
is that set on youtube stuff yeah and
that's how i went showtime with apollo
did you rub the uh the wood for good
luck anyone you know it's crazy yeah
yeah because people don't know this
either is um
i was doing these shows right but i
didn't have any money because i was
working at like uh you know like i was
taking odd jobs so i was i was i was
renting theaters and all this [ __ ] and i
was getting sponsors to pay for it so i
i so the back of the ticket would be
blank right so i would go to kinkos and
put eight to a page and cut them up
right so the front would say joe coy's
comedy jam and then the back is blank
and i was like ooh i can make those into
coupons
and and sell that as advertisement right
so i would i walked up and down the
street on charleston boulevard right is
if you're ever on maryland parkway in
charleston there's a theater there
called uh in vegas it's called the hunt
ridge theater and it's not in the best
place right it's it's pretty bad so i'm
walking up and down all these these uh
stores and i'm just like hey i'm doing a
show at the hunt ridge and i just want
to know can you sponsor me i'd love for
you to put your advertisement on the
back of these tickets it's already sold
out 800 people you know i mean we can
put your you put like a discount coupon
on here and i'll charge you like a
bucket ticket and everyone kept saying
no and i got to this oil place i still
remember it was like a auto repair shop
and i just
i don't know why i just walked in and i
just go hey i'm doing a show down the
street hunt ridge theater and i'd love
to like sell the back of this ticket
uh make it like a half off coupon for
oil change or whatever uh be like a
bucket ticket that's already sold out to
800 people and he goes
all right
i know what he goes yeah 800 bucks all
right cool
his name was paulo gotta
and then he and i remember he grabbed a
book of company checks and he wrote it
out joe coy entertainment llc and he
wrote 800 bucks and i remember my mouth
dropped like holy [ __ ] he just paid for
the venue
i was like what the [ __ ] and he ripped
that check out i couldn't believe it man
like and at this point you hadn't sold
any tickets no
no
no i haven't but i knew i'd sell it i
could get it oh yeah i knew i would sell
it out yeah yeah yeah and then i was a
proud of selling it out sorry i was just
good man i was good at like telling
people to buy tickets and so you were
going on the street hey well no no no
because people knew
me from coffee houses oh so i knew that
and then i was opening for people that
catch a rising star and and like ketchup
right as you start would give me two for
one tickets and i would hand them out to
my friends and like on a weekend show it
would be packed but it was all the
two-for-one tickets that i handed out
and i'm like well why am i giving this
headline all this money it's me so then
i started renting theaters
and i was like i'm gonna take this money
you're paying me 50 bucks a night but
i'm packed in the room yeah you know i
mean so then i started renting out
theaters and uh and that's how i started
selling that [ __ ] out
and i was a big fan of dota footwear do
you remember donna
so biggie would wear a hat the the tight
hat and like ll cool jay would you they
sponsored chris webber i think yeah no i
was there during that production and uh
and uh and there's this thing called the
magic convention it's the men's apparel
convention in vegas it's huge right
and uh yeah it's huge and uh and my
friends were b-boys and i used to throw
b-boy events right it was called
i got anyway what's it called illicit in
the game okay and uh and they were they
were huge that's why i know the
jabberwockies that's why if you watch uh
in his elements on on netflix the b-boys
segment the guy that's doing it ronnie
i've known him for 20 years oh wow and
and we we opened snoop dogg together
right at the blaisdell
[ __ ] crazy so like the where i shot
coming in hot at the blaisdell i opened
for snoop dogg 25 years before that and
snoop and ludacris were 20 no not 20
like 40 minutes late and they kept
making me go back on stage and they
wrote an article about me like joe coy
saved the snoop dogg show like i still
have the article cut out so it was so
crazy that the guy that wrote that
article
wrote the article for my blazo netflix
special black people's lack of
punctuality has done so much for your
comments yo right crazy yeah so so
they they were these b boys they were
dancers and they were like my friends
they were always doing my shows and uh
and they they they had a gig with tribal
street wear so they would dance at the
booths right during the convention
and i knew dada was in there because
i was checking in uh i was such a big
fan of the hat right yeah and i was i
was i was working the front desk at this
place called alexis park
and this this guy came up
and he's paying for all the wounds in
cash right young black guy right maybe
25 years old and he's paying all the
rooms in cash and i looked it up and his
name was damani and uh and it said dada
supreme and i'm like oh [ __ ] that's that
hat and by the way this is back in the
day when there was no internet yeah yeah
yeah so if you fell in love with that
hat that biggie was wearing you had to
find someone that lived in new york to
get it for you yeah because you're not
gonna find it on there's no internet
right you know or go through a magazine
like you know what i mean like source or
something to see if it's in the back and
maybe call the store
so i wanted that hat so bad right and uh
and i just looked down and go yo how's
it how's it working for that company and
he goes oh i love it i love it he's
paying for all the rooms cash it's like
10 rooms cash
i go damn that's that's incredible man i
i love that hat biggie wears that hat i
want that hat how do i get that hat he
goes i'll get you a hat i go really
oh that's dope man like uh like what do
you do he goes i own it i'm like what
yeah that's crazy what he goes yeah i
own it his name was demonic i forget his
last name domani and uh
and he sent his assistant she brought me
all this this merch and uh and i always
remember what he looked like right and
and when my show started popping off i
was like i'm gonna walk up to him again
and tell them about my show yeah so my
friends were b-boys and they were doing
tribal street wear the booth
and
those those the lanyards to get in were
like five six hundred bucks to get in
and they had two so they both went in
and then he would take the other dudes
yeah come back out and gave it to me and
i literally stood by the dada booth for
four [ __ ] days
i literally went every single day until
he came and he finally came and i saw
him i go that's that dude and i walked
right in that booth and i go hey man i
met you you gave me a hat he goes oh
yeah i remember you and i go yeah i told
you i did comedy she was like hey he
goes did you call carlos because he gave
me carlos the marketing guy's name name
and number and uh i go i called but he
never picked up and he goes he goes oh
carlos and then carlos pops up he pops
up from behind the the the rack and he
looks up he goes hey get over here he
goes this dude i was telling you about
he's a comedian i met him at the at the
at the hotel blah blah blah he's got a
comedy show
and uh and then carl was like i'm sorry
man i never got back to you he goes load
him up whatever whatever he wants so i
walk out of the convention with a bunch
of [ __ ] and then carlos who's my friend
to this day one of my best friends
he goes call me man because we want to
do a comedy show and we'll sponsor you
and he goes i'm sorry about that man we
just been really busy because they were
blowing up yeah they got the chris
webber deal they got the snoop deal they
were doing big [ __ ] he goes just come
come to office so i drove there my honda
prelude with one broken taillight drove
there second avenue los angeles street
you know what i'm talking about the the
garment district
and i remember i made this fake uh price
sheet i made like a fake price sheet for
a comedy show
and i was sitting i was so nervous man
because i thought i was asking for too
much money i think it was like 5 000
bucks for this comedy show because you
just give us a breakdown and we'll see
if we can sponsor it he goes lance is a
huge uh comedy fan lance is the other
owner he owns the footwear department
this is so much information you can cut
it down you got four cameras to cut from
yeah
and uh and uh and i'm sitting downstairs
right i got this this this whatever it
is that i made uh this price sheet and
then this big good looking black guy why
the af the biggest afro bro it's massive
he's got light blue glasses on
sunglasses light blue everything was
light blue all the way to the toes and
he and i hand him my thing goes i'm
lance he's like what's up lance and he
sits down he goes he goes yeah i'm a big
fan
like this and he goes
so this is the price i go yeah he goes
all right cool we'll do it
and he put it down and i go that's it he
goes damn man let's do this
oh [ __ ] i should ask for more yeah
and i walked out of there and from that
day on i was sponsored by dotto footwear
like from like 98 to like 2000 whatever
just doing comedy shows he the the
american express corporate card like
they would they would they gave me the
like an authorization form or whatever
so i could charge it all the hotel rooms
get out of all the comments yeah and
then all the flights they would book it
for me so when you see me do show time
at the apollo you'll see me wearing that
that hat that biggie wore this tight hat
yeah that's because
for me to fly the show to do showtime
with the apollo [ __ ] crazy isn't that
nuts and that that same magic convention
that's where you that where you met the
jabbawockee one of them no no i knew
jabbawockeez because i was throwing
b-boy events ah yeah yeah
those b-boy events that i was throwing
this is back when they were like 10 11
12. so when they're kids they were kids
i knew them when they were kids
so i i knew all those people i'm a b-boy
bro like russell seemed like kindred
spirits to me you are russell peters
yeah man for real like he's he's he's a
dj yeah but just in the hip-hop culture
oh hustler's been doing it for a minute
yeah got your respect doing [ __ ]
arenas like yeah you guys seem like
kindred spirits to me uh-huh yeah yeah
it's crazy right it's crazy how that all
came from circles
or 10 or 12 years old and then you see
them explode
yeah but when i met when i met ronnie he
was like 16 70 you know he's with full
force he's like he's like red bull bc
one champ like he's oh so he's the coach
he's the coach for the olympics now but
when i met him he was 16.
these guys were already very established
within no no they weren't they were just
kids they were b-boys but you saw they
blew up oh but you said when you met him
he was already sponsored by rebecca no
no no no no no he's a b now he's
sponsored by red yeah yeah yeah but when
we were just on the come-up like when i
was trying to do stand-up yeah by the
way the shows i did at the hunt ridge
always had b-boys and
so like i got footage of all that [ __ ]
like when are you gonna put on a dock
yeah i should have all these i have it
all man we're we're working on it but
like yeah people don't that'd be a real
i mean that footage alone from yeah it's
crazy apollo or comic view any of those
would be i got footage jb smooth
smash my shoulder when no one knew no
i'm talking like when no one knew yeah
but jb's but no one knew another planet
but you you don't understand no one knew
like this was like in the 90s it might
be the hardest
[ __ ] with
huh it might be the hardest i've ever
laughed i thought i remember i'm telling
you i i opened for him at uh
i was on this thing called the black
college comedy tour yeah you were just
saying and like i was the other yeah
so the roster was a bunch
yeah you were of black
part yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so so it was like it was like they had
the book they had to have diversity
right you couldn't put two black comics
on one show because
it's too many black people yeah you know
being at the college like you that's too
many yeah we need diversity yeah and
they were like oh we got diversity what
do you got you have an asian guy we got
joe court yeah but why guy joe yeah yeah
yeah you got a latino guy
so i was like all the others right it
was like me honest john and gary owen
idea
i saw jb in like oh seven so it was
later but it was on a show with david
arnold hosting rest in peace and david
by the way kevin hart was there i think
d-ray came through yeah and then they
had jb smooth close it out and i was
like heaven this guy closed it out who
is this guy and he [ __ ] lit the room
on fire he was in like inglewood or
something what year was that it was like
oh seven oh yeah you're talking about
the casino maybe maybe that's crazy
those were fun times set it on fire like
cat in the hat's room and all that yeah
maybe this i think was cat in the hat
and he did the leaning [ __ ] about the
[ __ ]
that's oh my god that was back in the
day those are fun nights